what's going on guys this is rob and the
moon knight trailer comes out today at
the time that we're recording this video
and one of the big questions a lot of
people have is who is ethan hawk going
to be playing in the moon night show now
the most obvious answer here would be
that he's playing like konshu when mark
spector's brought before the statue of
khanshu after basically being left for
dead by royal bushmen and those guys
they're like kanshu appears before him
makes a bargain that kind of a thing and
that's the line where ethan hawk is
saying like i sent so much chaos in you
or something along those lines that's
basically what he's saying right that
he's essentially kanchu and he's like i
can give your life order and meaning
right i can cleanse the chaos and all
that kind of stuff you know what i mean
now that's the most obvious thing the
big thing that i'm kind of going with is
that well if i had to choose one i'd say
probably randall spector but i'd say
he's probably going to be a combination
of randall spector and badeer now who
are these guys so over on comics
explained today we're releasing a video
if it's not out already that's literally
called moon knight randall specter
shadow knight explained the character of
randall had been around for a little
while but he's basically the brother of
mark spector the idea behind this is
that the two of them were basically
mercenaries together at one point in
time but randall had basically betrayed
mark spector for more money and then
left him and his crew essentially for
death now along the line there was a
point where mark spector basically
fought a guy by the name of hatchet man
the reality of this is that it's not
actually randall instead what you end up
learning is that in his journeys randall
along with his love interests had
basically come across this kind of
prophecy of sorts that basically meant
that if they fulfilled these particular
actions they could get the power of moon
knight and replace him this was a
driving force for randall because
randall had secretly witnessed mark
receiving the power of khanshu when mark
was left for dead by raul bushman and so
because of that randall was always
trying to achieve the same level of
power that mark had now all that came to
a head and ultimately the ceremony was
actually completed that using their
lunar energies combined with like magic
and so on and so forth then basically
randall ended up getting like
indestructible skin and super strength
he was basically a clone of luke cage by
all standards of measurement outside of
how he operated now eventually mark
specter and actually the punisher worked
together to basically defeat him and
then eventually mark spectre actually
killed him and he's basically been dead
ever since but in more recent years in
marvel comics specifically during the
current run of moon knight which is
still ongoing while there is the main
villain of zodiac who's recently kind of
come out of the shadows to reveal that
like he's the one pulling the strings in
secret that what you had was a guy by
the name of badir also known as hunter's
moon that what had happened here is that
when mark spector had basically met with
konshu and become konshu's avatar on
earth he was considered one of his fists
but everybody has two fists and so the
other part of this was badir known as
hunter's move but they never met before
it's because they never really had a
reason to meet before that by and large
throughout pretty much his entire
publication history of marvel comics
that moon knight always kind of fell in
line with like the mission of kanchu of
like what he was assigned to do on earth
it wasn't until more recently in the the
avengers run by a guy named jason aaron
that he had actually defeated consu and
basically defected away from what his
traditional mission was supposed to be
and operated as an avatar basically
using the power of country but not
following the mission of khanshu this
invoked hunter's move who basically
believed that mark spector was like
wrong or he was screwed up and had to be
corrected right brought back to the
proper past the two of them had a really
really really cool fight and for the
most part he'll probably just end up
lingering around for a little while but
the reason why i mentioned all this is
because if i had to look at ethan hawk i
would say he's probably a combination of
the two i mean there was a point in the
comics when randall spector had actually
approached the statue of kanchu and
tried to gain his powers and it simply
just didn't work and so take those two
elements and basically combine them
essentially say that what had happened
is that after mark spector had been
injured or whatever the case is by
whatever manner and whatever means that
randall had actually attained the power
of conscious kind of an antithesis to
mark spectre the big difference between
the two and the line when he says like i
sensed a lot of chaos in you is that
there's more specter as he exists and
then there's mark specter the way he was
supposed to exist so the big difference
between hunter's moon and moon knight is
that mark spector just has powers and
like he just fights people and that's
basically it with hunter's moon when he
officially became a fist he was
basically given what was called the gift
of course basically meaning he has
knowledge of all the moon nights or all
the the fists of konshu that came before
him in the same way that like t'challa
the black panther becomes a black
panther and then gains like the ability
to access all the black panthers before
him that's what was supposed to happen
with mark spector for whatever reason it
didn't and it's largely attributed to
like the multiple personalities that he
has and like how chaotic his mind is and
all that kind of stuff and like that's
basically it but imagine like that was
actually randall that randall is
basically what mark specter was supposed
to be but randall is a lot more violent
he's a lot more extreme he fits into the
archetype of himself as he's been
depicted in comics over the years which
is basically chaotic now another option
here and i don't really know whether or
not this would really be the case would
actually be zodiac right zodiac is the
antithesis of moonlight right i mean
hunter's moon is just kind of like the
other part right just like another
aspect of the moon night mythos like
that's it zodiac is the total antithesis
to moon night where moon knights serve
the purpose of like protecting those who
travel in the night right and making
sure like no harm comes to them he's got
the midnight mission so people can like
come and ask for help if they need it or
whatever the case is zodiac inflicts
chaos imagine if like moon knight's arch
nemesis was like the joker with moon
knight powers and that's basically
zodiac he's a really really really cool
character he's only appeared in a couple
issues so we have no idea what direction
his story is going to go in but he's
amazing so far it's entirely possible
that could also be uh ethan hawk as well
the important thing here though is that
the marvel cinematic universe prides
itself on simplicity right i mean here
on the channel anyway it's one of the
things that's kind of stung us more than
a few times we're like we kind of get
caught up in the idea of like the
possibilities and then we end up like
all the way out and and well not really
right field all the way out in left
field
and then it ends up being brought back
where it's like it was against all along
and that's it right i know all you guys
who believe that like mephisto was the
one pulling the strings in one division
all you guys were basically just kind of
like no not agatha mephisto you know
that kind of a thing it's part of the
fun of just like theorizing and just
throwing things out there but if we're
being practical here randall's the most
obvious choice what direction they go
with him i have no earthly clue randall
or zodiac or something basic like that
where he's essentially street level he's
part and parcel if not equal to moon
knight and like that's basically it but
i'm curious what i'm really really
curious to see where this goes again he
could very well just be conscious so
like you see ethan hawk when mark
spector first gets his powers you see
him appear to ethan hawke a few times
here and there and like that's it right
you only see him uh maybe like three or
four times over the course of the show i
could certainly see how they would do a
lot of billing for ethan hawke right
he's one of the most celebrated actors
in hollywood he's a big name when people
are like ethan hawks in the show he's
like damn this is going to be great
right i mean it's that kind of a thing
right the mcu is
whether you love it or hate it moving in
the direction of kind of building
franchises based on big names as opposed
to like the value of the franchise
itself right like hence eternals
swordfest i'm sorry for all you guys who
love the eternals it was okay
it's a movie that exists but by and
large you know ethan hawk's gonna draw a
lot of names it's just one of those
things where it could kind of go either
way whatever role ethan hawk plays
though this is one of the big downsides
to him playing konshu you would probably
see him not just in this season but like
in future seasons which is going to cost
the mcu a lot of money and for those of
you guys who are following a lot of the
news and stuff that's coming out there
now the mcu isn't doing these great big
huge contracts like they did with chris
evans and robert downey jr and guys like
that right those huge multi-year
multi-million dollar contracts those are
basically done right like you get a
contract for a particular set of events
or movies or shows or whatever and then
that's it whether or not we see them
again depends on whether or not marvel
wants to bring them back right so the
most likely scenario here is whatever
role ethan hawk plays will likely just
be for this season and if that's the
case it's got to be randall or it's got
to be like the deer or a combination of
both or some variation of that possibly
even raw bushmen right i mean there's no
indication he's playing that character
he seems to have a little more of an
intimate involvement in the life of mark
spector than just like a guy who
betrayed him and left him for dead again
you know it's just one of those things
it's one of those those interesting
concepts i mean he could also just be
like the the archaeologist right you
know that mark specter was working with
when he was basically ambushed by raw
bushmen and left for dead so that's
possible too now the other reason why i
also say randall specter here is because
he has had a lot of involvement i mean
being the brother of mark spector is no
small thing but in terms of him like
striking against mark spector he's
killed mark spector's girlfriend before
he actually caused a miscarriage with
marlene right the not really wife of
mark spektor but like mark spector's
girl at the time i mean the guys caused
a lot of havoc in the life of mark
spector one of the big issues you have
though when it comes to randall is that
marvel hadn't really done a very good
job of doing anything with him right
he's just an old school character that
appeared for a little while marvel
brought him back in an effort to drum up
interest that interest was there and
then after he was seemingly defeated he
just disappeared for something like 16
years and so it's one of those things
where if he does have a significant role
if it really is randall
marvel will probably beef him up a
little bit right give him more of a
personal involvement not only that
having someone that's that close to mark
spector as the main villain that's
something that we haven't necessarily
seen before in the marvel cinematic
universe we've only gotten that close a
couple times the first one is bucky
barnes in captain america when bucky was
the winter soldier and they were really
i guess brothers in so far as their
relationship as friends and then like
tony stark and obadiah sting and obadiah
stain was like a mentor father figure
but in terms of like a straight-up
biological brother right like they share
the same blood i'm not sure that's
something that we've actually seen in
the mcu so it's kind of charting some
new territory i think it'd be cool not
the most significant thing there ever
was not by any standard of measure right
i'm not saying it'd be the biggest deal
ever but it would really kind of anchor
the characters or anchor those two guys
together in a way that we haven't really
seen happen in the marvel cinematic
universe i mean i guess maybe you could
talk about loki like falling in love
with himself right like sylvia
but at any event i'm going with randall
right i'm going with randall spector i
could be 100 wrong and i don't care if i
am but i am going with it being randall
specter right i feel like that's the
most logical choice that's the person
he's most likely going to be he's going
to end up becoming shadow knight so with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace